la economía de ucrania ha quedado
tremendamente empobrecida en estos tres
meses de guerra en este país con enormes
incertidumbres sobre cómo y cuándo el
país logrará recuperarse de este
conflicto bélico según estimaciones
internacionales el pib de ucrania caerá
entre un 35 y un 45 por ciento este 2022
han caído los ingresos aduaneros ha
habido una fuga de empresas
internacionales y también se han
desplomado esas exportaciones y esa
producción de trigo y de productos
agrícolas que son uno de los pilares de
la economía ucraniana por otra parte los
continuos bombardeos también han
afectado a la infraestructura de este
país hablamos de viviendas de hospitales
pero también de plantas industriales de
puentes y de carreteras que este país
tendrá que reconstruir la consecuencia
más inmediata de estos zonas según el
programa mundial de alimentos al menos
10 millones de personas que están
pasando hambre
de momento aunque también este conflicto
tiene consecuencias globales ongs
estiman que 200 millones de personas
corren el riesgo de caer en la pobreza
extrema precisamente por la guerra en
ucrania